el diagnóstico hasta ahora es de un test
de antígenos que es un poco menos
preciso que el test de pcr que también
se realizó el presidente y cuyo
resultado se espera para esta tarde
según informaron desde casa rosada- de
la casa de gobierno esta tarde hora de
argentina con ese resultado sabremos a
ciencia cierta si se trata o no de 19 en
todo caso el presidente está vacunado y
se sabe que aquellas personas vacunadas
a pesar de que se pueden contagiar
suelen cursar una enfermedad leve
se supone que las vacunas previenen
sobre los casos en los casos más graves
de la enfermedad en todo caso llegaron
mensajes de aliento y acompañamiento de
apoyo al presidente de todo el arco
político y por supuesto esto representa
un llamado de atención para un país
donde aunque la vacunación no avanza a
paso tan rápido si hay muchas personas
vacunadas y tienen que tener presente y
esto también lo dijo el presidente
alberto fernández que la vacuna no es
una protección total y que hay que
seguir manteniendo los cuidados en el
contexto de la pandemia